my name showed I'm a product manager on
Chrome OS I'm here with my colleague Ben
and our friends from Samsung and
Gameloft
and we're going to be talking to you
about building and making sure that
Android games run well on screens with
devices with large screens so Ben is
going to be coming on stage shortly to
tell you a little bit about how you can
make android games work well with large
screen devices just before he does that
I'm gonna spend a few minutes talking
about why you should think about it
so we at Google spend a lot of time
thinking about gaming and part because
we have so many people are using Play
Store and many of those people do so
because they want play games so we think
about what games people are playing and
why and what games they're going to be
playing two three five years from now so
as we do that we're starting to see more
and more titles that pull players in
with immersive graphics immersive
gameplay and that makes sense to us
because mobile hardware has grown
stronger 3d capabilities higher
resolution screens and the android
framework itself has evolved to support
these with modern graphics API is like
Volcom and those immersive titles look
and play better on large screen devices
so when we talk about larger screens
what do we what do we mean well we're
really thinking about four things
Chromebooks is the team that I come from
tablets in our case Android tablets
devices that have mobile to desktop
extension and foldable phones and our
friends who sounds fun will be telling a
little bit about that so first
Chromebooks who here has a Chromebook if
you could raise your hand please oh okay
I have people raising multiple hats
which is which is awesome
so thank you for those of you who use
Chrome OS devices so for those of you
who are game developers if you have a
game in the Google Play Store it's
probably already running on Chrome OS so
I definitely recommend grab any Chrome
OS device load it up from the Play Store
and check it out now the way that works
is Chromebooks run a full version of the
android framework inside a container so
from your games perspective it's just
running on an Android device the
container connects directly to input
display networking and so on now you
probably know Chromebooks as laptops but
Chrome OS the operating system that
powers that is available on a bunch of
form factors desktops all-in-ones
detachable x' and now tablets and your
input is going to vary from device to
device your main input on a laptop is
going to be keyboard and some kind of
pointing device but when you go through
all those different types of devices
they can vary not if your device has a
touchscreen and not every device has the
same kind of input Chromebooks are in
growth according to NPD Chromebook
market share is growing I reached 26
percent based on unit sales in the US as
of now of 2018 and year-on-year market
share grew 34 percent so from our
perspective and we hope from your
perspective two Chromebooks are a market
that we think are worth keeping an eye
on have grown a ton in the last four to
five years and we expect that to
continue
second tablets so tablets have been
around on Android for a really long time
since honeycomb and today there's a
really wide variety of devices form
units that run on Chrome OS like the
pixel slate with a 12 inch screen
premium devices like the Galaxy Tab s 4
all the way to more affordable units
like the the tab a light 7-inch variety
of screen sizes variety of cost points
and
Android tablets we think are key so 19%
of all active mobile gamers play on an
Android tablet and that includes across
all platforms both Android and iOS so if
you're shipping a game on mobile this is
a sizable chunk of the people who play
it
third desktop extension so an increasing
number of phones like me Samsung
flagship since the s8 allow you to
connect a mouse keyboard and screen and
extend onto a larger screen usually
there's no touchscreen since you're on
an external display and just like Chrome
OS there exists a multi window systems
so that Apple game the window can be
resized and then finally foldables so
foldables are coming to the market soon
all sorts of interesting features like
dual display and we'll have the Samsung
team talk about that in more detail and
context of the Galaxy fold shortly so
that's a little bit about the space and
some of the why and to talk to you a
little bit about the how I'm gonna hand
over my colleague bet everyone my name
is Ben dable I'm a partner developer
advocate at Google and X game developer
and I'm here today to kind of talk about
it she had said some of the common
technical issues that you need to
consider when bringing your game and
adapting it for the guy he's larger
screen devices so maybe just start off
with show hands how many of you have
actually consciously adapted your game
for larger screen devices by adding
input you know extra input like keyboard
mouse or you know handling multiple
aspect ratios or resolutions anybody has
anybody done that with their mobile game
I see like a couple hands how many of
you are planning to do that maybe with a
game that you're launching soon or
sometime this year anybody else
a couple more hands okay so hopefully
after the presentation a lot more of you
will consider it so why is this
important right there's all these
different devices out there and as
Shahid said your game is probably
already
running on these larger screen devices
and it's important because as game
developers you know you obviously want
to provide the best possible gaming
experience for your players and so you
really need to kind of consider what
what kinds of devices that your players
are playing on it could be a phone in
portrait mode it could be a Chromebook
or samsung decks with keyboard and mouse
attached or soon foldables with multiple
displays configurations and aspect
ratios and you know you want your
players if they're downloading on one of
these devices to have a great experience
and you know can kind of really allow
you to expand the fun factor of your
game on these devices now I realize that
this sounds like a lot of work and for a
lot of game developers in other words
new platform or supporting something
that's not mobile is definitely a
challenge especially in the Android
ecosystem but the key thing to remember
here is that this is all still Android
and this is all you the same apk so it's
not like you're shipping a separate apk
for these other devices and one for
mobile they're all combined within one
apk and there's certainly you know
things you can do to adapt that one apk
for things like foldables or tablets or
Chromebooks
but what I want to focus on here is kind
of the best practices the stuff in the
middle there that will give you a great
baseline compatibility across all these
different devices and it's really kind
of boiled down I think to three main
areas screen considerations input
considerations and kind of building and
setting up your apk so that when it's
tributed it works across the most
devices possible and you know for
certain devices there's certain areas
that maybe there's more considerations
you have to think of or or deal with but
if you're going for the largest
compatibility across all these different
types of large screen devices you're
gonna have to kind of look at each area
so let's you know how do you handle this
with one apk let's kind of touch into
this right I mentioned it's only it's
the same apk across all these devices
how would you handle this so high very
high level you handle this
with configuration changes so in Android
if you're not familiar anytime the
system detects a device configuration
change it's gonna automatically restart
your activity and restart it with new
resources that allow your app to kind of
change and adapt for that new
configuration so the most important task
for you as game developers to kind of
consider is handling these configuration
chains configuration changes
appropriately so that your game will
kind of run seamlessly across no matter
what device it's running on or what kind
of things happen during gameplay by
default Android system will do this
automatically so a lot of you if you're
not doing it right now you're probably
just living with Android doing it
automatically for you it does this by
invoking on save instance State before
it will restart your activity which lets
you kind of save some information that
you need to kind of restart your
activity but for a lot of resource heavy
games this is not ideal because if we
really slow to restart the activity and
reallocate all those resources and in
the case of like dynamic resizing on
Chromebooks it can happen you can get a
lot of configuration change events you
know at least one per frame so it's
better to kind of think about and handle
this yourself so you know exactly how
your game is going to behave anytime a
configuration change happens so now I've
kind of touched on the high-level
aspects of configuration changes let's
see I would use them to adapt you know a
game across these devices starting with
kind of the screen considerations I
mentioned earlier so on devices like
Chromebooks and Samsung decks your game
by default is going to be launched into
a windowed environment or it can be
dynamically resize which is something
that you know a lot of mobile developers
don't really consider and on devices
upcoming like the Samsung Galaxy fold
you know the screen and aspect ratio
will change whenever the user opens
advise from the smaller screen to the
larger internal screen so each of these
cases is going to fire off a non
configuration changed event so to handle
this you simply need to declare in your
manifest all the configurations
you want to handle yourself dynamically
encode so in this example we're
declaring that we want to handle screen
size changes in orientation changes so
then in your code now your activity is
going to invoke on configuration change
whenever the screen size changes or the
orientation changes or whatever other
else configuration that you declare that
you want to handle so for example in
this case you could scale your OpenGL
content to match the new aspect ratio or
resolution to prevent things like
inaccessible UI elements or change your
input areas so they make sense on the
new screen so that's maybe how you'd
handle that kind of that case with
resizing now if your game is always
intend to run in full-screen which for
some developers that's that's enough or
maybe you need to you test it out on a
Chromebook and you find it's crashing or
something else bad is happening
you can always prevent your game from
being resizable by specifying resizable
activity to be false inside your
manifest should also note that if you do
prevent this however split screen will
not work on mobile devices and you know
we recommend that you if at all possible
really try to support the dynamic
resizing because you know a lot of
gamers want to have the game running
with maybe twitch chat or something else
up next to it so we think it's a valid
user experience in some case so try to
support it if you can so on the topic of
orientation right on port on mul devices
usually the default orientation is
portrait but on other devices it could
be landscape so you should specify in
your manifest the sensor orientations
that you support so that the system
doesn't you know flip your game upside
down or something else crazy happens
while people are kind of moving the
device if you're dynamically handling
orientation changes inside your code
make sure you use display dot get
rotation and be aware that the values
that you're expecting might be swapped
based on the default Hardware
orientation
so another thing to consider about
larger screen sizes is obviously the
resolution right there's more pixels and
a bigger screen means you should
probably provide higher resolution
assets one of the good tools around this
you can either handle this yourself or
you can consider using Android app
bundles what that will allow you to do
is to upload all of your assets for all
the different various screen densities
and then Google Play will automatically
ship whatever assets are needed to the
particular device that somebody's
playing on so this you know for example
if somebody's playing on a tablet it's
gonna emit kind of the lower resolution
assets or if they're playing on a mobile
device maybe it will emit the ultra-high
resolution assets this really saves you
valuable download space because it does
not go against your your download cap or
the size limit on Google Play and it
also really saves you the trouble of
maintaining multiple apks for different
devices so I recommend you look into it
and again with more pixels becomes more
or comes more flexibility with the UI
and HUD so if players are playing on a
larger screen consider the things you
can add expand or change to suit that
display also make sure that you consider
how readable and how big everything is
on a larger display display so for
example if somebody's playing on a TV
that's you know they're sitting 6 to 10
feet away from make sure all your fonts
are readable and that Ollie you know
asked elements of your UI are are
identifiable nothing's been frustrating
than trying to squint at a text on us
small text on a screen so that's some
screen consideration let's talk about
input now so more and more games are
delivering kind of a desktop or console
like experience right you're seeing all
these games that are kind of blurring
the line between something you'd find on
Steam or you know traditionally and now
it's being played on a mobile device and
you know a lot of those games are having
you know work as game developers kind of
assuming that it's going to be played
with a touch you know touch screen or
touch interface but you know the players
are going to be very disappointed if
they load up FPS game on their
Chromebook or something with keyboard
mouse attached and it doesn't work and
you know Android has had api's to
support keyboards Mouse and controllers
for a while but again a lot of game
developers don't consider using them
because they just assume it's going to
be a touchscreen device so the other
thing to kind of keep in mind is that
many these devices are convertibles so
they can switch configurations
on-the-fly so like a good example as a
pixel book where it can be in a
clamshell laptop mode and then you
player can switch it to a tablet in the
middle of gameplay right so really try
to anticipate all the different ways
that a play the configurations could
change during gameplay and support kind
of on-the-fly control scheme changes and
again we come back to kind of
configuration changes right how do you
detect this and how do you handle it so
the best way is to kind of specify in
your manifest configuration changes
around you know input devices such as
keyboard and handle these on the fly and
switch the control schemes based on what
configuration change events you're
getting inside of your code so you know
there's many ways to do this but one of
the ways you can do it is basically
query input manager at startup for
example or during a configuration change
and kind of pull the system to see what
hardware input devices are available and
also make sure they're usable right
because just because an input device
might be available it might not be
usable because it could be a Chromebook
for example where it's in tablet mode
and the keyboard is there but it's not
usable because on the back of the device
so it's really important to kind of
consider this and adjust this on the fly
and just adapt to whatever is usable
currently during gameplay and asphalt 9
here does a great does a great job of
this and Alex will be talking about this
a little bit later and if you don't
think keyboard support makes sense for
your game fair enough there's a lot of
games out there that it worked extremely
well it's just touch but you might
consider that improves accessibility if
you do add keyboard support so things
like skill key bindings player
navigation menu
camera control there's lots of different
things you can do just give players a
little bit of a interesting shortcuts or
improves the way that they interact with
your game if you really wanted to get
fancy you could also implement you know
custom key mappings and let players set
up exactly how they want to be able to
play the game and another thing you
should not forget about is as mice so I
use the Android API is we've got api's
for mouse capture where you can
basically capture the mouse in the
center of the screen which works
extremely well for third-person type
games or FPS is where you want the
cursor to be locked in the middle you
can request to capture the mouse pointer
it'll disappear while still sending you
kind of the motion events you need to
move the camera around or the player so
this is a key thing that will really
make those first-person shooter type
games or third-person controlled cameras
really like that much more usable on
Chromebooks because trying to do that
with a touch touch pad or touch screen
doesn't work so well all the time and if
you haven't implemented controller
support please consider that as well you
know a lot of people are using
controllers more widely across devices
like Chromebooks and Samsung decks and
all the standard Android controller
api's will work across these devices so
it's another great way to make sure that
he was providing one more option for
players to enjoy your game so that's
some screen and input considerations now
let's talk about just kind of how do you
set up your apk at build time and
configure it to make sure that it
supports all these various devices
running Android so first off you need to
review your permissions and features
that you're asking for and determine if
you really need them there are some
permissions and features that are
blocked uncertain or not they're not not
supported on certain devices like
Chromebooks so if you blindly ask for
them even what you might be in a
situation where somebody tries to go
download your game on the Play Store and
it says it's not compatible with that
device and sometimes it's not very clear
to the users
why it's not supported so good examples
of this might be GPS or SMS or even
rear-facing cameras so I just what we
recommend is that you list them as not
required in your manifest and then
encode just check to see if you have
that permission or if that hardware
feature is available and handle it
gracefully in code rather than just
declaring it as required at download
time also consider the hardware that
you're running on so you know a lot of
these devices have very different levels
of performance and so if you have an
automatic quality control system you
should try to test it on these different
you know on lower end hardware and more
beefier hardware to see how it behaves
and make sure it's doing the thing that
you expect if you kind of support things
like different performance quality
profiles consider adding some for
beefier devices like Chromebooks and
just you know adapt them to kind of
optimize for the device performance
potential that it has because when
players are playing on a more expensive
or a device with a larger screen they
might expect that it kind of looks
better as more fancy graphics features
there additionally you know what try to
provide an x86 build if you can I know a
lot of but a lot of developers are only
providing arm but consider that you know
most Chromebooks are x86 so providing
x86 or x86 64 builds is going to give
you a little bit of boost in performance
on those devices because otherwise
you'll have to have your arm binary
translated to run that system so you'll
incur a little bit of an overhead when
it automatically does that and for those
of you looking to get the maximum
graphics performance a lot of these
devices now support
Volken 1.0 1.1 coming soon so if you
look please look into that because that
will give you kind of usually will give
you a bigger boost in speed when running
especially on these larger screens and
finally test across all these devices so
you know add test cases that cover
things like minimizing maximizing
resizing
switching between the smaller and larger
screens you really want to kind of see
how your game is going to behave across
all these different these different
configuration changes not only that but
maybe there's something you're doing
with unreal or unity or your custom
engine that you wouldn't expect you know
something bad might happen at that level
so you want to make sure you're testing
to kind of see what if there's any
potential problems I know that you know
QA resources can be tight and game
developers are always trying to push
content as fast as possible quality
content so please try to use things like
you know you can use Android studio
Android and Chrome OS emulators to kind
of get a good sense of how your game
might behave in a short amount of time
or you could consider looking at
something like firebase test lab where
you can automate the testing process and
kind of get reports based on devices in
the cloud there so it's really important
to kind of test and make sure that your
game is doing what you think or what you
expect it is across all these different
device configurations so now that I've
covered the basics I'm really excited to
welcome our friends a Chanel boom from
Samsung to come up and talk a lot more
about the Samsung Galaxy fold thanks Ben
hi everyone my name is Ashe I'm a
partner Support Engineer at Samsung I'm
here with my colleague nawoon and today
we are going to talk about how you can
make your game works great on galaxy 4
we'll be talking about some general
specs and touch on few concepts like app
continuity and multi resume as you know
we announced galaxy fold on favorite xx
it introduces a completely new category
that unlocks new capabilities never seen
before with infinite infinity flex
display we created galaxy fold for those
that want to experience what a premium
foldable device can do beyond a
limitation of a traditional smartphone
galaxy fold is in a category of its own
it delivers a new kind of a mobile
experience along user to think to do
things they couldn't do with an ordinary
smartphone
galaxy pod is a culmination of eight
years of research and innovation
following the debut of Samson first flex
flexible display prototype in 2011 it
will be available starting April 26th
here are some important hardware specs
Galaxy fold is loaded with a seven
nanometer 64-bit octa-core processor 12
GB or dedicated ramp over 4300 mega
ampere battery providing users with
unmatched gaming potential that can last
for hours on a single charge now
when gaming with galaxy fold bigger is
better games are up to one point six two
times bigger in landscape and 2.4 times
bigger in portrait than galaxy s 9 plus
providing gamers with the most immersive
gaming experience anywhere seamless app
experienced player can receive a text
invite to join multiplayer game and
unfold to response right into the action
multi at multi active window experience
galaxy fold offers gamers ultimate set
up to play your favorite multiplayer
game while streaming on YouTube and
learning about excelling how how to
second ok ok thank you ok so multi
active window experience Galaxy Ford
offers gamers with ultimate set up play
your favorite multiplayer game while
streaming on twitch and YouTube playing
game tips for you to master your
competition performance galaxy folds
keep up with the heaviest gaming with us
over 4300 mega and for your battery
carbon water cooling system so you can
gain stronger
now on top of things that Google already
covered here are four things to keep in
mind while designing your apps for
garlic Galaxy fold or optimizing your
existing app number one unique aspect
ratio for galaxy fold to display cutout
3 app continuity for 3 app Multi resume
we are going to cover these in details
now supporting full screen mode is
critical to ensure that users gets the
best immersive experience and your app
take full advantage of bigger display
with no black bars let's see how you can
achieve this when folded galaxy fold
will have a longer aspect ratio or 20:1
ratio line for supporting full screen
you will have three options one if your
app target SDK is greater or equal to 26
then it will run in full-screen mode but
if that's not an option for you then set
resizable activity as true this will
also enable multi window mode for your
app in our upcoming slide we will be
covering this in detail resizable
activity as true or false could be set
in activity or application tag in your
manifest file now this too is not an
option then the last resort is to add
maximum aspect ratio of 2.4 as the cover
as as the cover screen aspect ratio is
21 ratio line this metadata needs to set
under application tag and will allow
your application to take full advantage
of full screen next is the display
cutout galaxy fold has a display cutout
when unfolded in the top-left corner
make sure your app is properly handling
the cutout and no necessary information
is obstructed because of that cutout in
the highlighted portion in this image
you can see the cutout the good news is
that there
there are standard Android APs and that
can be used to make sure that your app
is optimized to properly handle these
screen cutouts later in our slide we
will share the resources and important
link that you can follow to access the
relevant Android AP eyes now to go
through the details depending on the
fact whether your app renders in the
cutout area your app can use get display
cutout API to retrieve display cut out
objects these api's let you check
whether your content overlaps in the
cutout so you can reposition if needed
you can set layout and display cutout
mode to one of the following values more
default this is the default behavior in
this content renders into the cutout
area while in portrait mode but content
is letterbox
while in landscape mode mode short edges
content renders into the cutout area in
both portrait and landscape mode mode
never content never renders in the
cutout area here's the code snippet
showing how to implement short edges in
a style dot XML file in short edges
content renders into the cutout area in
both portrait and landscape mode all
right now I'm going to invite my
colleague Nabu to talk in details about
app continuity and multi regime thank
you okay hello everyone my name is now
and I given up the same sums under the
framework I'm going to explain some
important things for you to keep in mind
about foldable devices first app
continuity with the foldable devices now
developers will be able to control
multiple displays on a single mobile
device user will have more in each
mobile experience going back and forth
in this place here Google Maps
demonstrates our app continuity the user
experience is unfolded from the kaabah
display to the immersive main display
the the map information will be laid out
in a bigger display also information
which you are looking for at the Kaaba
display will be seamlessly transitioned
to the main display but to ensure this
wonderful experience your apps must be
prepared accordingly these are the
requirements that need to be met to
ensure the desired app continually first
asked me to be able to handle to
physical screens second helps me to
proper handle folding and unfolding it
means handling with the screen size
changing last because of Pittacus screen
size changing we strongly recommend to
be resizable as you already know the
galaxy fold is foldable device what does
this mean
foldable device can physically fold its
display changing each screen size
accordingly this is why garage fold has
two different screen properties for the
two different screens you can check more
detail on the screen how can you handle
this two different screen sizes this is
no different from other masses of
support different screen sizes on
Android because the galaxy fold is a
member of under family the only
difference is that it will be happen
much more
at karate fold once posted screen size
had been properly handled the app need
to react to folding and unfolding for
the collage fold develop past do not
need to handle and special api's nor
events for folding and unfolding galaxy
fold follows conventional under the
platform behavior for screen size
changing due to the screen size changing
the compilation will be changed to the
following screen size smallest the
screen size and screen layout again this
is not different from other methods of
handling computer changing has been
already covered this topic developers
can save and restore data or handle it
sizing with change the computer to
ensure this seamless experience between
this place we strongly recommend the app
Billy sizeable once again this is
because to Pittacus screens critically
displaced has two distinct screen
properties once the resizable
appropriately handles that change the
computers the user will have an
intuitive and seamless transition
between the cover and the main displays
foldable devices are the next new wave
of mobile devices more and more will be
list into the market in coming months
and years
be free fare for this movement earlier
and make your apps easily sizeable
sooner is always better next point is
multi region
multi-region means resuming all tab bit
of activities in multi window in handle
pie if have an OEM obtain all tab
visible activities are legend multi-item
expect to become mandatory behavior in
next version of Android of course
Samsung opted in this feature with our
devices all Samsung devices above under
the pie including couch fault support
multi room or prying motive ISM is also
super easy just add metadata into
manifest file of yours just like this
then your app is visible with multi
window situation your activity will be
resumed app developers can now test how
their apps responds in a folder
environment this enables them to verify
that is done correctly by using on
emulation environment that is provide
for app continuity at multi-region
pretty check more details on our lease
or society okay so far we have explained
several constellations for collapse
fault
please remember this Kellogg fault is
also on Android device
if you follows standard Android
principles for different devices and
phone factors there is no problem with
collect fault this is why we collaborate
with Google on this project since the
beginning here is Leo gaming experience
on garage fault I took this video from
our partners a game logged who works
very closely with the college fault now
I'd like to welcome Alex
develop for game hoped to share their
experience developing multi devices
thank you and enjoy the video
by the way I played the game
and did you that night this space is
surprises
it's a little bit long previously the
iconic for the date with prison wait
did you see that okay here is Alex thank
you I'm Malik Silvano I'm a graphics
engineer at game love Barcelona and I'm
gonna talk about some high-level ideas
of that we follow to make the Aspen in a
truly multi device game so first of all
you probably already knew but that's 1/9
is an arcade racing game with lot of
cool expensive real supercars racing at
crazy speeds in beautiful real-life
locations it's a great team so you
should play please so the mobile centers
to you you usually think about these
things when building your game which are
basically hard constraints but that's
not true and it shouldn't be like that
because nowadays you need to support a
wide variety of devices with many
different deep put methods and a huge
range of performance levels and that
okay you should target as many devices
as you can to reach as much people as
you can so for us it was really helpful
to develop for an unknown device with
all the possible options and variations
and invest in a really good platform
abstraction layer software that allows
the programmers to work without platform
specifics some sort of simulator so in
the context of user input you need to
know what the user wants so don't assume
your input method based on the device
detect each input device and use the one
that makes sense in your game and the
plain intentions and by the plain
intention I mean that for example if
they have a controller connected to the
two devices because probably they want
to use it
so the specific input bytes can be
disconnected at any time for whatever
reason you should be able to adapt to
that situation without interfering too
much in the gameplay so for example
pausing the game as soon as the device
gets disconnected and then we come back
from it and of course you should always
let the user choose between the
available input methods but be careful
with genetic you is our control
mechanics it's device had it has its own
dynamics and some interactions may not
make sense a rolling in order so moving
on to UI what we can say is invest in
indoor tools in our case we chose to
develop our own UI editor that it's
called Jing we name all our tools after
drinks for reasons and is it using it is
used in old game love personal projects
and allow us to design implement and
test all the UI related assets in the
game so now I'm gonna briefly go through
some of its features so you can see how
we work with it Jin has an integrated
source image management tool there allow
the artists and designers to import high
quality high resolution images in the
most popular formats so we impose
minimal restrictions here as they can
apply some optimizations later so as a
first of the incision step we can group
those images based on the usage the
context inside the game mode if they're
in same menu something and quality
requirements this helps with loading
memory and quality management and this
is what the user decides which
compression profile to use I'm gonna go
to that later and if they want to create
min maps for for the Atlas those members
are used in case
you're using a low-resolution device and
it helps with flickering and pixel
crawling we can also animate every
element on widget using either keyframe
animations or events for sounds and
particles this is greatly abused by
designers and artists and are a very
important part of our which is have some
kind of animation also as a way to
improve productivity there's a template
system is it used to create reusable
layout computations that can be filled
with content
this of course saves a lot of time
creating new similar screens or menus
and make easier to keep a consistent
look throughout all the whole game so as
we mentioned before in part there are
lots of different devices you need to
support so one of the main challenges
when designing is how to handle the wide
variety of ratios and Orpha speculations
and pixel densities they have in our
case for gin we can offer all the menus
in specific key aspect ratios directly
in the editor and we can swap between
them at any time we have the most
commonly phone and the devices will
target available at any time you should
never put UI elements in absolute
positions of sizes all our widget
position in is defining ratios or
percentages either relative to the
screen or a container hierarchy and the
size is translated into pixels later on
on rendering using the device reported
DPI but in extreme situations when
there's no choice we admit defeat and
allow the use of letterboxing but this
is only done for the country for the
content that really needs it the 3d part
of the game is
always correctly visible and adapt it
adapt to any aspect ratio so I'm no
designer but I asked our UX team for
some general tips to take into
consideration when designing the UI that
you might find helpful so sometimes the
extreme differences in important methods
impact navigations flow and comfort in
those cases you will probably need to
redesign the layout to make it work with
a specific input device in mind
localization can impose some strong
restrictions in InDesign there are
significant size differences depending
on language used and you need to be able
to test it quick in some languages there
are also characters and don't match
particular styles for example a common
example is numerals in some languages so
it's important to adapt them and then
this probably belongs more to invest
into a part but allow you to users and
programmers to forget about local
conventions like dates you need or
currencies make a way to do the
conversion internally to make it look
good not only at the language level but
on different locations too for example
in this particular example only the
third option allows programmers to
forget about formatting and let them
express clearly the type of data they
want to use regardless of the aspect
ratio use natural scrolling whenever is
possible natural meaning in the dominant
direction of the aspect ratio because
when scrolling year you usually focus on
the center of what you are scrolling but
previous and next elements are part of
the past and future of what you are
exploring so those elements are going to
be easier to talk about the important
information or anticipate anyone if you
see it those elements
static screens are boring but don't be
too intrusive and you can use those
animations to guide the user attention
where needed
in our case that would be the store and
of course and this is probably my part
maybe of course you guys need to be fast
there's few things as frustrating as
trying to interact with an app to find
out that it lags and doesn't do what we
wanted when you want it so be careful
with rendering performance this is
obvious but you guys can be very complex
with lots of semi-transparent animated
layers geometry is usually not a problem
we are probably talking about hundreds
or thousands of polygons but trocols are
especially on portable devices so but of
course especially in mobile be careful
with favorite a lots of big transparent
objects can really really hit
performance so uses many opaque objects
as you can because they can activate
some not obvious Hardware optimizations
if you pop if the platform supports it
it's widely available use frame buffer
fetch or equivalent on its API for
efficient program of all blending you
can also use it to implement some
popular photos of like blending modes
that could be harder to to achieve using
normal hardware after landing
capabilities and lastly image
compression is key for good performance
we're not the same group the image is
based on the compression needs in our
case we basically have four different
profiles shown here increasing quality
and you probably notice that we treat
alpha separately and this is because in
many situations when
using semi-transparent images is better
to preserve as much quality as you can
on the edges and then I'm gonna give it
back to Ben so we can finish thank you
thanks Alex
so let's kind of sum up here what we
talked about today so you know hopefully
you know listening to all the speakers
today you guys kind of have realized
that you know Android gaming is not just
phones anymore it's not just mobile
devices what you think of traditionally
as mobile devices you know players are
experiencing your game probably right
now
on a wide variety of devices and form
factors and screen sizes and you know it
seems might seem like a lot of a lot of
different stuff to consider but you know
it's again it's all just the the key
thing I wanna stress this all just it's
all just Android and it's the best
practices for Android and by spending
just a little bit of time considering
these use cases you'll really can take
your game you know beyond just a mobile
device and adapt it for all these larger
screens and provide that like best
possible gaming experience across all
these devices and you know that's really
important because your players will
thank you for it and they'll think that
this game is amazing when they booted up
on a Chromebook or I booted up on a
Samsung Galaxy fold you know we're
really committed to making this process
easier for game developers moving
forward so we've got a number of things
that are kind of in flight and coming to
help support you guys in supporting
these devices such as crostini so
developer tools on Linux on Chromebooks
additional profiling tools emulator
improvements so you guys can test a wide
variety of cases and you know further
game game controller support for these
different devices so we've got a lot of
information please check out our links
here unless you guys take a picture of
it but we've got one for kind of and the
Android site and then another one
specifically on the
supporting Samsung Galaxy fold and fold
walls from Samsung and I want to say
thank you all very much for coming today
I hope was informational informational I
hope you guys learn something I hope you
kind of consider these larger screen
devices moving forward I want to thank
our friends at Samsung and Gameloft for
coming to speak as well we're not going
to do QA up here but if you have any
questions please come up to the podium
here and grab it's after the session
happy to talk more about anything you
guys might want so again thank you very
much please fill out the survey as well
for the sponsor session love to hear
some feedback positive or negative and I
hope you guys have a great rest of you
GTC thank you very much
[Applause]